wann das motto wenn die spannungen
zwischen dem iran und den usa steigen
taucht regelmäßig das schreckgespenst
einer sperre der straße von hormus auf
schon 2012 hat us präsident obama eine
blockade als rote linie für die usa
bezeichnet
doch wie groß ist diese gefahr
tatsächlich und welche auswirkungen
könnte sie haben heute in vechta kompakt
die straße von hormus
[Musik]
14 riesige öltanker meist mit mehr als
150.000 tonnen fracht passieren im
täglichen durchschnitt den flaschenhals
zwischen dem persischen golf und dem
arabischen meer das sind etwa 30 prozent
des weltweit auf dem seeweg gehandelten
rohöls 80 prozent davon landen auf
asiatischen märkten allen voran in china
auch das iranische öl wird hauptsächlich
nach asien exportiert nur 18 prozent
gehen in den eu-raum der transit ist
aufgrund der enge und tiefe sehr
schwierig deshalb verläuft der
internationalen schiffsverkehr über
sogenannte verkehrs trennungs gebiete
sie regeln die ein und ausfahrt das ist
zum einen die straße von hormus im
hoheitsgebiet des oman und zum anderen
das verkehrs trennungsgebot tom vor uhr
dieses gebiet wird auch von den emiraten
beansprucht ist aber unter iranischer
kontrolle eine hohe see also ein
seegebiet außerhalb nationalstaatlicher
souveränität gibt es bei der straße von
hormus nicht aber sie rechtlich gilt sie
als internationale mehr eingehen
hierdurch vertreten die usa und iran
unterschiedliche auffassungen was das
recht auf transit für kriegsschiffe
flugzeuge und u-boote betrifft zu den
us-interessen washington verfolgt bei
seinem engagement in der region seit der
iranischen revolution 1979 unverändert
zwei ziele den ölfluss durch die straße
von hormus zu kontrollieren und das
festsetzen einer anderen großmarkt in
der regierung zu verhindern
als es während des iran irak krieg zum
sogenannten tanker krieg kam in dem die
beiden streitparteien die tanke des
gegners angriffen sahen sich die usa zum
eingreifen genötigt sie wie sehen die
damals starke iranische marine in ihre
schranken
welche möglichkeiten hat nun der iran
die bandbreite reicht vom aussetzen des
durchfalls rechts in seinen
küstengewässern über die bloße
ankündigung einer sperre und einer
befristeten blockade bis zur vermietung
die militärischen und technischen
voraussetzungen sind vorhanden
sofern feindliche schiffe in iranische
gewässer vordringen
ist mit schwarm attacken iranischer
schnellboote zu rechnen
auch attacken mit schwärmen kleinere
boote leerung vorstellen kann
doch schon die glaubhaft die ankündigung
einer sperre hätte unabsehbare folgen
für die weltwirtschaft
der rohölpreis würde in ungeahnte höhen
schnellen pipelines auf der arabischen
halbinsel könnten ein ausfall des
schiffsverkehrs nur in geringem ausmaß
kompensieren
allerdings werde der iran selbst am
stärksten von einer blockade betroffen
weil sie eine haupteinnahmequelle
versiegen würde auch china als
wichtigster abnehmer iranischen öls wäre
vermutlich sehr verärgert welche
gegenmaßnahmen während zu erraten die
ungehinderte passage in der straße von
hormus ist für die weltwirtschaft von
vitaler bedeutung
sollte der iran den unwahrscheinlichen
versuchen der blockade unternehmen würde
dies eine noch stärkere isolation des
landes bedeuten und vermutlich zu einer
eskalation mit den usa führen
denn washington hat immer wieder
klargemacht dass die usa gewillt sind
freie passage für die schifffahrt und
somit den ölfluss auch mit waffengewalt
sicherzustellen
gemeinsam mit den arabischen verbündeten
könnten die usa eine enorme schlagkraft
entwickeln der der iran nicht allzu viel
entgegensetzen könnte vorrangige
angriffsziele könnten marineeinheiten im
persischen golf die am barren sowie
raketenstellungen entlang der küste
seien allerdings werde teheran in der
lage mit seinen raketensystemen us
stützpunkte und ballungszentren auf der
arabischen halbinsel empfindlich zu
treffen
wie groß ist daher die gefahr einer
blockade
allgemein betrachtet nicht sehr hoch
denn sie würde vor allem dem iran selbst
enormen schaden
allerdings ist nicht auszuschließen dass
sie zu kleineren vorfällen kommt die zu
größeren auseinandersetzungen führen
so zum beispiel bei der kontrolle von us
schiffen während ihrer passage durch die
iranische marine in der regel gilt dass
die iraner nur wenn sie wirtschaftlich
und politisch mit dem rücken zur wand
stehen mit einer sperre von hormus thron
das war im juli 2008 zehnter fallen doch
schon wenige stunden später wurde das
entsprechende statements
johannes von iranischer seite
relativiert das größte risiko einer
amerikanisch iranischen konfrontation
besteht jedoch in kleineren
auseinandersetzungen die auf
missverständnissen und verständigung
fehlern beruhen
angesichts der angespannten lage im
gesamten mittleren osten könnte dies der
sprichwörtliche tropfen sein der das
fass zum überlaufen bringt alle akteure
wären also gut beraten sich in
zurückhaltung zu üben